make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are done with Thanksgiving
week and we are back to our regularly
scheduled programming and as promised we
returned with the boys and in this one
we're doing the origin of Frenchie now
here's a cool thing
Frenchie's origin story is actually
really cool like it's a really cool and
enjoyable origin if not probably one of
the funniest because with everything
that goes down you're just kind of like
but really though like it's it's it's
pretty cool right so Frenchie ends up
coming back from the war whether they're
the big war and it's kind of a funny
thing because he comes from a small town
right he doesn't come from like this
great big huge place right I mean you
know honestly I'm not very knowledgeable
about France geography you know I mean I
took French in college and bombed it
entirely
you don't really through me often with
French or the gender of pronunciations
right like a code in English is a code
in French it's like a code is one word
for a guy's code and it's another word
for a woman's coat and it's kind of like
all right that sort of throws me off but
unless you know it's one of these things
were at lipski's from an exceedingly
small town a town where like everybody
knows everybody else and there's
something kind of homey about that but
there's something kind of homey about
coming from a place where everybody
knows your name you know where where
basically everybody knows who you are I
don't mean to invoke tears but like
where do I knows who you are right there
something kind of comforting about that
now the funny thing is of course with
Fritsche having left being greeted by
his by his mom and its dad the first
question he asked here is really what
ever happened to Marie and the cool
thing is that we end up learning that in
his younger days French she was in love
with a young girl named Marie and for
the most part it was like a summer of
passion right now the nature of of being
like young and in love is that it really
is usually just a passion fuelled thing
well I can't really think of very many
70 year old people that I know that I
grew up with who'd stayed with the first
woman that they were with right I mean
does it really happened too much it's
just kind of a really it shows like a
summer fling is really what it was now
you know and ultimately he ends up
finding out that when it happens that
when he'd left basically he came he came
face to face with mister steal yo girl
that what he had in his younger days is
he had a schoolmate Oh kind of a rival
schoolmate basically a guy that you see
in arguments with her fights with all
the time that was named black Pierre
really his this it's really just Pierre
but he called him black Pierre now
here's the funny thing about this is
we're not really given like the full
totality of the experience between these
two guys when they were younger we're
only given it from the perspective of of
Frenchie really it just kind of looks
like Frenchie was a dick and just like
bullying this kid all the time so in
reality
that was the case I don't really feel
bad for Frenchie right like the guy he
was being bullied came out on top he was
like yeah man you bullying me all the
time
you know you gave me gave me a hard time
all the time so you went to the war you
gave me grief
I took your girl like what do you want
me to tell you man it's just the way the
game gets played and it's kind of messed
up too because he's just like hey man
like I jacked you girl like she's mine
now
so that's basically it just rides off
laughing at him now here's the worst
thing about it all is it basically she
hitched her horse to a guy who's riding
around on a bike let's just kind of take
note of this for a second right Frenchie
is being talked trash too by a guy who
stole his girl and this guy's riding off
with his girl on a bicycle right so
let's let's just kind of take that in
let's take that in for a second it's
kind of pitiful but ultimately Frenchie
drops into a really bad place now here's
the here's the thing about this is what
reasons why I think this is so cool
here's the thing about this this is
probably the most relatable thing ever
every single person and for those guys
who have never really been in like a
committed relationship we're never
really you know devoted your heart to
somebody before whether it's a kind of a
passionate short-term fling or whether
it is something serious then when the
time comes when it ends everybody goes
to this point right everybody goes to
this one we're just like you feel like
the world is ending I like everything
you know and love has come crashing down
around you and everybody needs that
right everybody needs that that kind of
release you know where you just sort of
just kind of spill your heart out there
and maybe spilling your heart out comes
in the form of the drink which is
dangerous because he can lead you down a
really dark path but other times just
going and working out but you got to
find a way to release that to kind of
cope with your with your frustration
your anger and your sadness of the
situation and it's interesting to see
how how Frenchie does this in so far is
he just kind of wallows in a sorrow now
of course everybody does this but you
can't do it forever right otherwise you
just end up being the guy who just feels
bad for himself all the time and that's
basically yet but his father ends up
coming to him and basically saying
you've got to get revenge on black
Pierre you've got a fight back and
you've got to get your girl back now and
my personal philosophy I don't really do
that right I mean it's one of those
things where it's like you know if she
really cared about him that much she
would go back to him she would just
leave the guy she's with and go back to
him friend she doesn't really matter
that much to her because she didn't make
that choice why she stayed with the guy
she was with as it was it's kind of a
smart move by Frenchie to kind of say no
that's not really the game that I play
now it's not Frenchie being a sourpuss
here right it's not him being a wimp his
argument is I don't like violence and
having been in the war and having seen
the full brunt and the full totality of
just how terrible human violence can be
it's a rightful stance to take it's a
rifle situation if you're like I've seen
the worst of
humanity and I do not want to go back to
that place again you know so what this
basically does is lead to the festival
of the saints of haha I guess is really
what this is my French is terrible this
is probably the coolest festival ever
because what these guys do is they
basically do joust right where they do
Geoff's where they're riding their
bicycles and they have like these
gigantic baguettes and then basically
just like charging each other with these
things I would do that would be amazing
to see the real question is how stale
are these baguettes right guess there
comes a point where things get so still
they just kind of crumble so I guess
it's gotta be just before that point
where it really is like getting hit with
a stick biggest stale bread can hurt man
like it really really can't but in the
middle of all this black Pierre is
really kind of like the champ kind of
like the way the channa but he's kind of
one of the top guys here and the issue
is that the father of a French you
really kind of use them as a coward
because you won't fight for what's his
right he won't he won't stand up and say
like that's mine and I'm gonna go fight
for it right and again this is when
things get kind of crazy when it comes
to the notion of law and it comes to the
notion of romance you know when it comes
to the notion of hey like but like she's
a grown adult though so like she can
kind of make her own choices and that
kind of thing the issue here is that
it's not really just about Marie anymore
it's really more of the family honor
insofar that what you had is you have
black Pierre who essentially took
something from from Frenchie left him in
a vulnerable state made him look weak
and then Frenchie is doing nothing to
correct that and so what it does is it
makes Frenchie's family look weak and so
as a result so that his father shows up
and basically challenges black Pierre to
a baguette jazz which is kind of hard to
take serious but at the same time it's
amazing and ultimately in the middle of
all this but what isn't happening is of
course you know Freddie tried to stop
and says hey look man your old your
heart can't handle this and ultimately
you end up having black Pierre who more
or less cheats ends up like ruining the
bicycle and they're really kind of
tripping up Richie's father which since
him flipping over and basically kills
him and so in response to that Frenchie
loses his mind because it in his in his
mind he's basically lost it all now
right because he's like his mom died
shortly after from despair so he
essentially like this guy stole his girl
and then killed his mom or killed his
dad and then his mom died because of his
dad's death right black Pierre cost him
everything and so it's kind of crazy
because at that point it's like alright
well now it just comes down a general
principle right like now it comes down
to okay this guy stole my girl that
sucks you know like I can I can find a
new one whatever you know but like he
killed my dad now and like that's our
fault so like that's one of those things
where you kind of okay so black Pierre
black Pierre needs to come to an
understanding about his place in the
bigger pick
my peer needs to be reminded where he
resides in the great sphere of things
and I am going to do that as basically
what Frenchie says then adapt when he'll
having lost everything that was valuable
to him he ultimately injured was kind of
walking away from from his village right
like just sort of going out and roaming
the world but not before taking his
revenge on black Pierre
but basically stringing him up and
running what looks like basically a rope
through his mouth and out of his
backside and then in turn giving the
finger to Marie
leaving her hanging and saying like like
when she came back into the please take
me back he was like not chance proof and
ultimately ended up bailing in there
from there just started rowing from
place to place now this is when Billy
butcher comes into play and this is kind
of a funny thing that really kind of has
to be asked here is how is the Billy
butcher really seems to keep running
into these circumstances where he keeps
finding these various guys you know he's
always kind of like in the right place
at the right time because what is up
going on here is that Frenchie's in this
bar and in basically like while he's
hanging out in this location so American
guy runs up on him and is like like you
know where he basically knocks it with a
drink of Frenchie looking for a fight
the responsive Frenchie is buy me a new
one and of course this this American guy
is like nah man
consider a payback for us saving your
backside during World War two and it's
kind of crazy because this guy basically
champions the actions of America during
World War two is like look how great we
are but was never actually there right
ladies is basically taking credit for an
event that he was never really part of
and so as a response to that fridge
she's like okay well then fine then you
look much like like the year I'll help
you understand your place in the bigger
picture and basically instigates an
entire bar fight and takes on all these
guys by himself and that's what billy
butcher was looking for billy butcher
was looking for a guy who wasn't
necessarily broken but a guy who had
basically been pushed to his limits a
man with nothing to lose and that's one
of the things that that really makes a
guy Moe are the most dangerous what a
man has nothing to lose he's not afraid
of anything he has no fear there because
there's nothing else for him to lose
anymore right I mean he's not afraid of
losing his family he's not afraid of
losing his friends because he doesn't
really have any or anything like that
it's basically just him in the world by
himself and so ultimately fringe is a
guy who can take all comers and that's
really what it is that's really why
Billy butcher wanted him is because he's
a man as at his wits end and doesn't
really you know it's really kind of like
you at his limit and at that point
that's what he wants he wants a guy on
his side who will do whatever it takes
to win because ultimately he doesn't
have to worry about repercussions for
anything except for himself this was one
of those things were fringy Zaid he's
kind of so long as they don't catch me I
don't really care what happens right
can't do anything to me they can't take
anything for me because I have nothing
left to take it's really it's really one
of the reasons why I would argue Frenchy
it's probably the most dangerous of all
the boys but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments explain
and make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the Rob port if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]